really something else babe
don't you forget it kept man [ __ ] you
blame me look at her I love you so much
sure I got a lot of problems but my
relationship isn't one was it bad girl
last night wasn't it I just hate
thinking about you being with Ken rents
coming up daddy you heart my sweet peace
that ass girl well worth every damn
penny you just took sugar daddy with a
DVD winger in a big old bank account 68
big ones I usually paint that sweet I
just want to make you happy
you know what would make me happy
sixty-eight thousand dollars now kind of
plan in and out likes nothing nobody
gets hurt
relax take a chill pill okay you haven't
you never kill anyone before
but you're like never have like hell we
are
let a woman manipulate you into murder
and kidnapping you gotta learn how to
stand up for yourself can I at least get
off my knees hurt ready to party chip
but that one the best nice you lie boy
get your head in the game don't even
think about it skank
what
[Applause]
[Music]
this is not exactly what I call help the
relationship chip yeah no kidding
[Music]
dimples I love them
[Music]
you